en el vídeo anterior introdujimos las
nociones de enlace entre átomos y enlace
iónico donde un átomo es capaz de tomar
electrones de otro átomo y dado que uno
de ellos termina con una carga positiva
y el otro con una carga negativa se
atraen entre sí ahora iremos al otro
extremo del espectro de los enlaces
donde en lugar de robarse electrones
unos a otros los van a compartir imagina
que estamos trabajando con dos átomos de
oxígeno tenemos uno por aquí un átomo
neutral de oxígeno que tiene 8
electrones en total pero sólo 6 de ellos
están en su capa más externa entonces
tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 electrones de valencia
observa que hicimos los pares hasta el
final de manera que tenemos estos dos
electrones de valencia que no se han
emparejado con otro electrón
ahora dibujaremos otro oxígeno con otro
color distinto para darle seguimiento a
los electrones tenemos el otro oxígeno
por aquí y también tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6
electrones de valencia ahora al oxígeno
de la izquierda para convertirse en un
átomo más estable le encantaría ganar o
compartir de alguna forma dos electrones
y por supuesto al oxígeno de la derecha
también le encantaría ganar o compartir
los electrones más de valencia entonces
cómo pueden hacerlo qué tal si el
oxígeno de la izquierda comparte este
electrón y este otro con el oxígeno de
la derecha y el oxígeno de la derecha
comparte este electrón y este otro con
el oxígeno de la izquierda
bueno si lo hacen vamos a obtener algo
que se ve así tenemos nuestro oxígeno de
la izquierda tenemos nuestro oxígeno de
la derecha y la forma en la que
indicaremos que comparten estos dos
electrones es con una línea como esta
esto nos indica que hay dos electrones
que comparten estos dos oxígenos y vamos
a decir que estos otros dos electrones
también se van a compartir y lo
representaremos con otra línea así ahora
podemos dibujar los electrones de
valencia restantes este oxígeno de la
izquierda tiene además de los electrones
que está compartiendo cuatro electrones
más de valencia por su parte el oxígeno
de la derecha también tiene otros cuatro
electrones de valencia
algo interesante aquí es que los
electrones compartidos harán que estos
dos oxígenos se mantengan juntos si no
se mantienen juntos estos electrones no
se van a compartir entonces lo que hemos
creado aquí se le conoce como enlace
covalente
lo interesante es que esto permite que
los dos oxígenos de alguna forma sean
más estables desde el punto de vista del
oxígeno de la izquierda tiene 6
electrones de valencia pero ahora puede
compartir los electrones más recuerda
cada uno de estos enlaces cada una de
estas líneas representa 2 electrones por
lo tanto este oxígeno dirá hey ahora
tengo 1 2 3 4 6 8 electrones para su
disposición y lo mismo será cierto para
el oxígeno de la derecha ahora hay
algunos enlaces covalentes que se dan
entre átomos distintos
por ejemplo pensemos en el agua
hablaremos de los enlaces entre el
oxígeno y el hidrógeno tenemos al
oxígeno por aquí una vez más dibujaremos
sus 6 electrones de valencia 1 2 3 4 5 6
y si tengo el hidrógeno tenemos un
electrón de valencia
entonces pensemos que el hidrógeno está
aquí con un electrón de valencia y por
acá tenemos otro hidrógeno con su
electrón de valencia y ahora el oxígeno
y los hidrógenos forman enlaces
covalentes de hecho así es como se forma
el agua entonces cómo se verá esto bueno
tenemos al oxígeno por aquí tenemos
estos dos pares de electrones y ahora
este electrón que tenemos aquí se
compartirá con el hidrógeno y este
hidrógeno compartirá ese electrón con el
oxígeno esto formará un enlace covalente
con este hidrógeno y por su parte este
hidrógeno comparte sobre electrón de
valencia con el oxígeno lo que formará
otro enlace covalente con este nuevo
hidrógeno ahora por aquí una vez más el
oxígeno pretende que tiene 8 electrones
de valencia
[Música]
468 y los hidrógenos pueden pretender
que tienen dos electrones de valencia
sin embargo la diferencia esta vez es
que el oxígeno es mucho más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno están a la
derecha del oxígeno justo aquí en la
esquina superior derecha sin contar los
gases nobles donde están los átomos que
les gusta acaparar electrones así que te
imaginas qué sucederá bueno los
electrones en cada uno de estos enlaces
covalentes van a pasar más tiempo
alrededor del oxígeno del que pasarán
alrededor del hidrógeno entonces como
los electrones pasarán más tiempo
alrededor del oxígeno vamos a tener más
carga negativa alrededor del oxígeno por
lo tanto tendremos una carga parcial
negativa en el extremo del oxígeno esto
en las moléculas del agua y vamos a
tener una carga parcial positiva en los
extremos del hidrógeno de la misma
molécula
y si te parece curioso este símbolo que
estamos utilizando para parcial es la
letra griega delta minúscula se
representa así por una convención en
química ahora bien debido a que existe
una cierta polaridad es decir un lado
tiene más carga que el otro a este
enlace covalente se le conoce como
enlace covalente polar